[Music]
in marketing backlash news
i hope it's the one i like these which
one i want to know what it is i know
what it is
it was something about [ __ ] i forgot
what it was but i'll tell you once it
comes up
okay i heard it in passing you know when
you hear something in passive yeah and
then you're like that's the one
is it the is it the gillette commercial
yeah that's the one oh
yeah because that's the one i wanted to
hear oh okay i thought
you were that was because you wanted the
backlash oh which one did you want back
you haven't seen it is there backlash
behind i haven't seen it what are you
doing
like a hundred thousand dislikes and
then they bought 10 000 dislikes well it
looks like they bought it because
there's no positive comments at all like
zero
but it has 10 000 likes like positive oh
like
it has 10 000 likes but zero positive
comments and it has a hundred thousand
dislikes
got it i saw the video i want to watch
it i want to see it
that's the one i wanted i was hoping
because it was preachy but we'll talk
about it
submitted by joe's pinky toe gillette
was my first deodorant
the kind that the yellow one yes you go
like this and it looks like the lucas oh
yeah yeah
oh and like the honey you know they have
yeah yeah it goes through the like
little hole yeah yeah yeah my first one
was brute
what brute i never really even broke it
yeah that is
no no i heard it called ajax
my secret one was like that too i think
it's by gillette though
um anyway gillette faces internet
backlash and a boycott over a recent
commercial
do you remember their jingle gillette
the best the men could get oh the best
that's the gorgeous fish like the way
john remembers it
but he said do you know that was a
question
all right i'm going to show you guys the
ad um
you can tell me what you think about it
i saw it so beautiful is this the best a
man can get
that's why we can't laugh at all
i remember that because the boys
watching today
[Music]
will be the men of tomorrow yeah that's
the man of the tomorrow
what if the kid on the bottom was
winning like that for new jiu jitsu and
he was setting them up for like a
camera or something and i had him in a
triangle dad
he's like what are you doing why are
people mad about that video
man it was so cinematically yeah it was
so why are you mad let's talk about that
why
i should be mad no i'm not saying you
should or shouldn't but i like to i like
to hear the other perspective because
most people are mad so
most people are mad about that yeah
because i think it's it's good that
they're trying to teach this but i do
think that you can't preach to the choir
meaning most men
are cool like that that's why they're
mad so and then and then
the the ones that are very like sexually
harassing crimin
criminal and [ __ ] these guys are like
a very small percentage of guys and we
don't like them
yeah well i think what they're trying to
aim for is how it's
so remember how we talked about how uh
masculinity is now considered toxic by i
forgot who but someone really important
like some
things that was really important yeah
but yeah what do you remember i don't
remember it was a person psychology or
something yeah it was like toxic yeah
whatever yeah so they mean
we know exactly what we're talking about
now they're saying we're experts on
i read a lot of articles i don't know
but the point is
albert einstein said i heard but the
point is that now masculinity is labeled
as
being toxic right toxic masculinity and
so they're trying to approach
the stereotypes of like how macho men
should be and like how
all these guys that you're saying that
small percentage like that's how
a lot like the boys will be boys thing
and like you know how
all the catch phrases they're using i
don't even understand them
like me neither you're saying boys will
be boys like what does that mean
it's just like that's a pretty common
saying though people say that
it is common but i don't know what that
means because for me boys would be boys
means
they're careless like they're always
going to forget or leave a shoe in here
in context yeah so that's one context
another one is when they flirt with
girls or whatever
if they do that well it's like well
that's just boys being boys or they try
to grow
i thought that's creeps will be creeps
no it should be used
for that that's why i think that it's
not clearly defined
where what i'm saying is that's just
[ __ ] behavior
is what they do that's not real
masculinity that's not
i mean real alpha dudes don't do that
[ __ ] so that's why they're
that's why they're mad is because
they're feeling like they're being
preached at when they are already not
people that exactly oh so it's guys that
are mad
saying how can you say that all guys
yeah yeah
exactly why are you calling me a sexist
racist
i see because i'm a white straight dude
or whatever part of that
but then the other half of the people
are getting mad to me seem like they are
the ones that are like this and they're
getting upset that it's being called out
in their face like i want a cat call
because they're calling it feminist
propaganda and they're saying like
it kind of is though it is and what's
what's dangerous about it is because you
have these people that are kind of on
the fence that'll see both sides
and it pushes people the direction like
i don't want to be [ __ ] preached too
i'll do whatever i want you know that
and so that's kind of why well what this
does though
is it is it makes it seem like there's
more
[ __ ] up guys out there than there
really are and that needs to change
versus addressing that hey there's a lot
of great guys out there
but there's this small number of
[ __ ] that need to be taught right
that's like saying you've been like yeah
we know you're not that yeah but if you
see
you know like i didn't mention that
they're like there are some out there
whatever but they did say something
you know i grew up around a lot of women
right so like with that being said
that phrase boys will be boys if you
guys did grow up around a lot of kids
was said a lot all right so when kids
would when when you see boys you know
this too when we were getting fights
like they're just being boys right and
they would we would
allow i've heard it for rough housing
yeah but you know it's not really
they're getting [ __ ] up you know i
mean it's not rough housing kids boys
are getting [ __ ] up and as adults i
always saw it as a kid too even when i
would get in fives
i just leave them alone they're just
fighting each other right they're just
[ __ ] each other up
so there are stuff to this that does
make sense and as a man i'm seeing that
[ __ ] and it makes sense to me
so like we can't just sit here and deny
that a lot of this stuff isn't just true
right because i also grew up with
the cat calling thing 24 [ __ ] seven i
saw it all the [ __ ] time this isn't
something i didn't see
like i saw it all the time guys coming
up grabbing girls on the ass
that's why i'm saying like i feel like a
big majority of people that don't see
it they don't realize that it's there so
they're getting offended
yeah so like i think like it's it's half
and half right and my bigger thing is
it's like
there is truth in this it's not it's not
completely false and also the fact it's
a [ __ ] commercial i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm offended that they're offended
because the way that i see it is this
right it's like
the way that i see it is none of that
stuff applies to me
so i'm good so i'm good but i know it
exists in the world
so for me it's like okay let me move
over and let this message
reach the person it should reach but why
am i
i feel like the people that are offended
are like if it feels so self-righteous
where they're like they think they know
the world and like ah
it's like it's not speaking to you
obviously so why are you getting
offended
for them trying to like even with the
people that are saying like oh all
chinese people can't drive i can't drive
too
but if if i could drive it just happens
to be right yeah but if i
but if i could drive then i'm like oh
yeah like i'll just well they're not
talking about this chinese guys i'm
about that chinese guy
yeah i think for what they're trying to
achieve here too gillette what they're
trying to achieve is to get more guys
involved
in fighting again like sure it might not
apply to you but will you step up when
you see it happening to someone else
like that are you allowed to step
up with facial hair i don't know if and
i'm trying to get to the bottom of this
is are they coming out with six blades
on a razor that's another reason people
are like why am i getting this from my
razor blades what's the real message
here you've got new shaving cream coming
out
if this is the type of guy that you are
i don't think you see this commercial
and go oh that's me i need a change
that's the other problem so you're
they're just blankets
let me put on some [ __ ]
deodorant before i go out and tell the
world
yeah so then are we saying then that
that these companies should just stick
it
should stay in their lane and not have
an opinion not what i'm saying no no i
know but
i know no one's saying that in this
group but then i'm just kind of putting
that question out there like should
brands have an opinion about [ __ ] i
think that this is so
polarizing that i i think
it's different than just having an
opinion like okay
so chick-fil-a for example is super
christian they're closed on sundays
they've made some
the owners have made some um anti-lgbt
statements in the past that they got in
trouble for
but they didn't make a whole commercial
being like this is why being gay is
wrong you know like or whatever
they didn't broadcast their point of
view to the
in a commercial of theirs whereas this
is like
broadcasting a whole point of view being
like everyone buying our razors is
sexist
and they need to stop or that's how it's
perceived by their majority
yeah the majority it's so much so of our
customers that we need to make a
commercial to them
well but if you're thinking that then
you're you're pretty [ __ ] stupid
right if you look at a commercial and
then you go oh so you're saying this is
what
you're pretty [ __ ] dumb like if you
have an ounce of intellect you can look
at it and say
oh i can see who this applies for right
i think that's that's the point
i see it that way it works both ways
right so if they're making a blanket
statement or whatever that's how you
feel
like shouldn't you be smart enough to
know that it doesn't apply or apply to
you and
in that commercial so i i'm kind of
seeing the other side of it but in that
commercial
you know how we watch daytime television
yeah so on daytime television it's
marking towards
all people all the time so they have the
like a fall and i can't get up button
right so it's like for old people when
they fall down life
i don't watch it and go what you think i
fall down all the time
i know it's not for me it's more of the
person that doesn't fall down i can't
remember what
life alert customers are those people
but the gillette customers but in that
commercial too they also had
they also had the guy correcting the the
bad behavior you know what i mean like
saying hey like that's not what we do
bro like that's
no but it's like they're showing them
this is how you should be acting exactly
like like as if you're watching an
airplane safety video they're not
speaking to their
don't take the mask and they're
preaching they're preaching to their
demographic instead of speaking to
and relating to their demographics like
if you bought a soap and you love a soap
you're buying the soap you love this
dish soap and they're like
hey ladies we need to stop using our
bodies to attract men we are more than
just our bodies we need to stop
exactly we need to stop and they're like
talking to you as if you're just some
broad generalization of a woman
rather than a specific individual yeah
and and for the majority of the customer
base it's not true
so then it should have been the reverse
then it should have been uh all the guys
doing all the dope [ __ ] and kind of
applauding that
yes yeah yeah well i mean i think they
would have had a much better result yeah
than being preachy i think a company
that kills it is like nike
you know how they'll have like michael
jordan and it's like it's the ten
thousand shots i missed it's this
whatever i failed or it's like whatever
yeah but they're always hitting the
positive mark it's very inspiring well
like the girl one that they said
like you [ __ ] lazy [ __ ] sitting on
the [ __ ] couch you need to go be like
michael jordan right
so it's inspiring versus this it's like
shame on you and it's
yeah yeah yeah dude i ain't one of these
guys yeah but i mean that's why my
initial reaction was
oh yeah that's cool because like we
should say that to those guys
for sure i can see the other effect
where it's like what are you talking
about dude
yeah like i do all those things it's not
like the message was wrong it's not like
these things don't happen
it's just how it says the way that they
said it they just felt attacked right
away because it's like
yo i just buy your razors dude like i
don't know that's what i've
grabbed some ass you know coming out
with 10 razor blades or something
yeah now you've you've helped me realize
the other side too because i was really
confused why people wearing i just don't
give a [ __ ] it's a commercial
yeah you know what i mean that's what
i'm boiling it down to where you want me
it's like god
chill but you also don't have a fickle
mind so a lot of people can be
upset at how things are marketed because
of the perception
of normies and sheep right
they can watch this video so like let's
say you know someone can watch this
video
and it could further reinforce their
uh idea of toxic masculinity this
buzzword that's been going around
and then now men and women are both
highly sensitive looking out for
toxic masculinity behavior which causes
oversensitive people
when they're like what was that david
what did you mean by that that sounds
like some toxic masculinity coming out
when you're talking about ufc
fighting it's like uh like cancel
culture [ __ ] exactly that's how it
manifests is because
things like this kind of content keeps
coming out and then
it now it keeps being reinforced into
these people's minds
that it actually exists when we're just
looking for boogeyman
not saying that it does it doesn't exist
it does yeah we need to deal with it
but not at this level right not not not
like this
it's not severe it's not code red this
is also why the
uh chinese products don't change their
marketing for 80 years
same packaging on soy sauce since 1950
that's right kikkoman soy sauce has been
the same for a hundred years can't
offend anybody they don't care about
brandy they got in trouble recently
they did i forget i take it something
racist or something i don't remember oh
they're always doing some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
but that's new school
they put the [ __ ] black guy in the
[ __ ] washer and then he came out
but that's my school stuff i'm talking
about this stuff
branding has not changed yet the only
thing that changed is the english
lettering on it
other than that the bottle looks exactly
the same that's what i'm talking about
you